Jason this is it we're we're gonna pitch
something here we go guys
we are ready to announce that we want to
we want to have a Netflix show yeah we'd
love to have a Netflix show Netflix if
you're watching this and you've decided
to to take a risk and take a chance calm
down there's more of us your family
we're ready for a fun Netflix show we
have some ideas
Netflix meet with us or do you guys want
to fix any other questions yeah
take the whole squad like like Drake all
my friends at school remember all you
guys wanted to remember whenever I was a
little kid
no elementary school I had no friends
oh my god we make a lot of money off
this guy this please the most important
thing you get all those ad deals right
thank you for everything we're gonna go
put him back in his box now like a coin
for this guy
how's it for the win with this squad
it's the best I love these guys I mean
it's so easy filled with everybody we've
filmed for like three years now and
having this today and it's the best
so I really appreciate if it's a life
changer I'd do anything for him I'd kill
someone for him ever something you were
like no I can't do it or don't show that
video no never
all the time now everyone wants shut us
down every wants to be my friend no one
used to not want to be my friend this
costs a lot of money but I know you can
afford it here we go what's the most
money you spent on a prank on a prank oh
crap I don't know a video we spent like
over a hundred grand I like my 420th
video yeah I was a lot like ten so you
almost had to cover that I don't have
any I don't have any money left yeah no
I pay for the mic one vlog that you felt
maybe went too far oh we had we had his
we had his big brother with his big
brother jump over a pool with a moped
and he ended up being hospitalized and
the nurse was like it was like it took a
50/50 percent chance of him surviving
that one went too far is there one big
day and it is in the medical update is
she's okay is there one bit that you
were afraid to do yes actually a bunch
of people always come up to me and they
want me to shoot him in the leg look
with a real gun and I will not do that
by one time oh so no one's like you like
that one it was one person you would
never prank I would never prank my
roommate Alex why is that he's to Falcon
of us all yeah to all of you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]